It is Saturday morning.
Erica and her dad ride bikes to the bakery every Saturday.
Erica always gets a hot cinnamon bun.
"Bye, Mom," Erica says as she runs out the door.
"See you later," Mom says.
Erica's dad waits at the end of the drive with his bike.
Erica jumps on her bike, and they ride to the bakery.
When they get there, Erica parks her bike.
She runs inside and says, "I'll have my usual, Mr. Hoffman."
"I'm so sorry," the baker says.
"A lady just bought all the cinnamon buns."
Erica runs out of the bakery.
"Dad, someone bought all the cinnamon buns," she explains.
"A lady with a big bag just came out of the bakery," says Dad.
"She was wearing a polka-dot dress," says another man.
"Does anyone know where she went?" asks Erica.
"I saw her go down the street on a black scooter," says a boy.
Erica and her dad ride after the lady on their bikes.
Soon, they ride past a woman on the sidewalk.
Erica asks, "Did you see a lady in a polka-dot dress?"
"She turned right at the corner," the woman says.
Erica and her dad turn right at the corner.
They see a black scooter in front of the art center.
They park their bikes next to it.
They go inside and see a bag on a table.
"That looks like a bag from the bakery," Erica says.
"I think you're right," says Dad.
The bag is empty.
"We'll have to use our noses to find the cinnamon buns," Dad says.
Erica smells the smell of cinnamon coming from a room down the hall.
Erica walks into the room.
"Hello, Erica," says Mrs. Garcia, the art center teacher.
"Help yourself to a cinnamon bun," she says.
"Then come help us paint."
They had found the cinnamon buns, and Erica felt happy.